du sérieux et de la détermination
deux ingrédients qui ont permis aux
templiers d'elancourt de tenir leur rang
contre les pionniers de touraine lors de
la 4e journée du championnat de 2e
division
score final 21 6 première victoire de la
saison à domicile ou en gros jeu au sol
c'est ça qui nous a permis de tenir le
match entre guillemets on prend pas
beaucoup de yards en défense donc on est
pas mal là dessus il faut qu'on
s'améliore un peu sur le jeu à la passe
et puis qu'on soit plus efficace quand
même restée savoir ces termes là tout ce
qu'ils ont fait on l'avait vu à la vidéo
sur leurs deux premiers matches
y a rien que nous a vraiment surpris à
la fin du match il n'avait plus vraiment
de réponse à face à notre attaque donc
ils mettaient beaucoup de pression on a
réussi à inscrire que deux trois brèches
pour sombrer sens pas se profiler de
l'an et ça a bien marché pour nous seul
bémol de ce match référence ce touch
donne encaissé en fin de match par les
templiers d'elancourt sous une
température glaciale une séquence de jeu
qui a eu tendance à agacer le staff de
l'équipe quand le match passe bien on a
tendance à se relâcher et c'est vrai que
si on met par la gueulante sur la touche
on a vite fait de se disperser et c'est
vrai que faut que les gars se rappelle
que même si on est devant c'est
important il faut exécuter jusqu'au coup
de sifflet parce qu'on sait jamais ce
qui peut se passer
on a vécu trop de matches de telle sorte
qu'ils sont retournés en deux minutes et
on se retrouve le bec dans l'eau à la
fin du match ton coeur pourrait pas que
ça se reproduise au classement les
templiers toujours invaincu reste
deuxième de la poule 2 ils sont toujours
en course pour les playoffs de fin de
saison
prochain match le samedi 4 mars sur le
terrain des corsaires d'evry